Quel est le rapport entre Joseph Pulitzer,
Jules Verne et American Horror Story? Un
indice, c'est le titre de la vidéo.
Le rapport, c'est Nellie Bly, et on va voir
pourquoi tout de suite.
Nellie Bly est née Elizabeth Cochrane, en
Pennsylvanie, le 5 mai 1864.
Elle perd son père à l'âge de six ans est
est d'abord destinée à devenir gouvernante
mais elle s'intéresse très tôt à l'écriture.
A seize ans, elle lit un article du Pittsburgh
Dispatch incroyablement misogyne appelé «Ce
pour quoi les filles sont faites»: faire
des enfants, et le ménage, en gros.
Elle adresse une lettre bien sentie au rédacteur
en chef pour lui expliquer sa pensée, il
la rencontre alors, et lui lance le défi
de l'engager si elle lui propose un meilleur
article.
C'est très vite chose faite grâce à un
papier qu'elle lui rend sur le divorce.
Elle prend alors le pseudonyme de Nellie Bly,
d'après une vieille chanson folk américaine,
notamment pour protéger sa famille car les
articles qu'elle s'apprête à écrire pourraient
lui causer du tord.
Elle montre très vite qu'elle ne va pas se
contenter de la rubrique chiens écrasés:
pour l'un de ses premiers reportages, elle
se fait embaucher dans une fabrique de boîtes
de conserve et y observe de l'intérieur les
conditions de travail des ouvrières.
Elle est l'initiatrice du journalisme d'investigation
et du reportage clandestin, qui restent sa
marque de fabrique par la suite.
Elle témoigne de l'insécurité, des faibles
salaires, du harcèlement des patrons...
Son reportage fait exploser les ventes du
journal mais il subit alors des pressions
de certains industriels.
Malgré le succès de son enquête, Nellie
est rabattue vers les rubriques arts et théâtre.
Pour se changer les idées, elle décide en
1886 de partir six mois au Mexique avec sa
mère.
De là elle envoie au journal des articles
sur les mœurs et coutumes, la vie culturelle,
cassant les préjugés que les américains
ont sur ce pays...
Mais elle écrit aussi sur le gouvernement
mexicain envers lequel elle se montre très
critique.
Elle devient menacée sur place et décide
de précipiter son retour en sachant qu'elle
risquait d'être bientôt expulsée du pays.
Elle tire de cette expérience son premier
livre, Six Mois au Mexique, dont le succès
lui permet de quitter Pittsburgh et d'aller
tenter sa chance à New York.
Encore une fois on lui propose un défi:
Joseph Pulitzer, du New York World, lui promet
de l'engager si elle parvient à enquêter
sur l'hôpital psychiatrique
de Blackwell Island.
Elle s'installe alors dans une pension pour
femmes et s'y fait passer pour folle, jusqu'à
se faire embarquer pour cet asile qui avait
déjà une réputation assez sinistre.
Là elle simule si bien la folie que les médecins
décident de l'interner après un examen médical
qu'elle trouve dérisoire.
Durant son séjour plus elle essaie de sortir
de son personnage, plus les médecins la considèrent
comme gravement atteinte.
Elle reste dix jours dans l'hôpital, observe
les mauvais traitements, les humiliations,
la nourriture infecte et l'incompétence des
médecins et
des infirmiers.
Une telle situation est loin d'être exceptionnelle
dans les asiles de l'époque.
En France, un scandale éclate à l'asile
de Clermont l'Oise en 1880 après l'assassinat
d'un malade par l'un des soignants; mais
même si on parlait beaucoup de rumeurs sur
les hôpitaux psychiatriques, personne n'était
encore allé voir directement ce qui s'y passait.
A sa sortie elle publie son reportage sous
la forme de feuilleton, dans le journal de
Pulitzer où elle est engagée.
Le succès de ce reportage est énorme et
lui fait gagner en crédibilité.
Il amène un scandale sur l'hôpital de Blackwell,
qui subit une enquête et est forcé à améliorer
les conditions de vie des patientes, et de
manière plus large le budget alloué aux
hôpitaux psychiatriques est augmenté.
Face à cet engouement elle publie son histoire
dans un nouveau livre, Dix jours dans un asile:
ce type de reportage devient très populaire,
c'est à cette époque que l'image du reporter
qui fouille et perce des secrets se popularise.
C'est le début de la Yellow Press, ou presse
à sensation.
Sa méthode est aussi reprise par Albert Londres,
qui publie Chez les fous en 1925 après un
internement volontaire.
Et puis la saison 2 d'American Horror Story,
qui montre le personnage fictif d'une journaliste
s'infiltrant dans l'asile de Briarcliff, s'inspire
fortement de son histoire.
Pour ce qui est de Nellie, le reportage clandestin
reste sa spécialité.
Elle se met dans la peau de domestiques, d'ouvrières,
et en 1887 elle pénètre l'entourage d'un
trafiquant, Edward Phelps, qui est traîné
en justice suite à son reportage mais pas
condamné.
Nellie est une «stunt girl», une reporter
cascadeuse, et d'autres journalistes suivent
son exemple par exemple en testant des traitements
médicaux ou en pénétrant des corps de métiers
parfois dangereux.
Revenons un peu en arrière pour la suite
de l'histoire.
En 1872 paraissait Le Tour du Monde en 80
Jours de Jules Verne, dans lequel le personnage
de Phileas Fogg faisait le tour du monde en
80 jours.
C'est quand même bien fait.
En 1888, Nellie Bly émet l'idée de tenter
de battre ce record.
Son rédacteur en chef est tout de suite enthousiaste.
Ooook...
Bon un an plus tard l'idée revient sur le
tapis, et elle est cette fois soutenue par
Pulitzer.
Ce défi est pile le type de journalisme qui
plaît aux gens, et le fait qu'elle soit une
femme ajoute une difficulté: parfait pour
le business.
Le New York World ouvre même les paris et
offre un voyage à qui estimera au mieux le
temps nécessaire pour son périple.
Son voyage est aussi l'occasion de mettre
en valeur les droits des femmes: le Philadelphia
Inquirer titre à
son sujet:
Le 14 novembre 1889, elle embarque donc avec
une seule robe dans ses bagages à bord de
l'Augusta Victoria, d'où elle arrive à Southampton
six jours plus tard.
Elle prend le temps de passer par Amiens,
où elle rencontre Jules Verne: il est très
enthousiasmé par son projet et lui dit «Si
vous le faites en 79 jours, je vous applaudirai
des deux mains.» , mais elle n'a pas le
temps de s'attarder: elle prend le train
pour Brindisi, traverse Suez et la mer Rouge,
arrive à Singapour le 18 décembre...
Elle ponctue son voyage d'articles sur les
lieux qu'elle traverse, et apprend à Hong
Kong qu'une autre journaliste, Elisabeth Bisland,
a été envoyée par le Cosmopolitan Magazine
pour la doubler.
Elle continue alors, arrive à Yokohama début
janvier, puis à San Francisco le 20 janvier.
Les quatre derniers jours, Pulitzer fait affrêter
des trains spéciaux pour accélérer son
retour.
Dans les gares par où elle passe, des orchestres
jouent, des journalistes l'interviewent...
Elle arrive finalement acclamée et accueillie
par des tirs de canon à New York, après
72 jours, 6h et 11 minutes, et plus de 40
000km parcourus.
Jules Verne déclare alors:
Elle devient la première femme à réaliser
le tour du monde sans être accompagnée d'un
homme.
La précédente, Jeanne Barret, l'avait effectué
un siècle plus tôt mais était accompagnée
d'un homme et s'était même travestie pour
l'occasion.
Si son histoire ne vous dit rien, j'ai déjà
parlé d'elle dans un précédent épisode.
A son retour, elle écrit Le Tour du Monde
en 72 Jours mais surtout un jeu de l'oie est
publié en son honneur.
Et ça c'est de la consécration.
A son retour, elle s'éloigne peu à peu du
journalisme même si la défense des conditions
de vie des ouvrières reste un de ses principaux
combats.
Et en 1895, elle épouse un millionnaire,
patron d'une fabrique de bidons de lait et
de 42 ans son aîné.
Ok.
Après la mort de son mari en 1904 elle reprend
elle-même les rênes de l'entreprise.
Elle brevète de nouveaux types de bidon et
engage surtout de nombreuses réformes pour
améliorer les conditions de vie de ses employées:
meilleurs salaires, assurance santé, centres
de loisirs et bibliothèques ouvrières...
Mais elle est escroquée et doit vendre l'usine
en 1914.
Elle part alors pour l'Angleterre et devient
correspondante de guerre pour le New York
Evening Journal.
Elle y découvre aussi le combat des Suffragettes
et, de retour à New York en 1918, elle continue
de publier sur les conditions féminines,
le monde ouvrier, l'enfance... et de s'investir
pour le droit de vote des femmes.
Elle meurt à 57 ans, le 27 janvier 1922.
Elle est alors décrite comme la «meilleure
journaliste d'Amérique», et le prix Nellie
Bly Club Reporter est décerné aux meilleurs
travaux produits par des jeunes journalistes.
En 2018 il a été décerné à Jodi Kantor
et Megan Twohey, pour avoir lancé le mouvement
#MeToo.
Je veux pas m'avancer dans des prédications
de mauvais historien, mais je pense qu'elle
en aurait été fière.